about 2 000 tons of cocaine are produced
every year that's almost double the
amount that was made a decade ago and
Colombia is at the heart of this boom
satellite photos showed that about 200
000 hectares of land were used for Coca
last year that's five times more than
there were at the height of Pablo
Escobar's Medellin cartel the global
Fallout is showing up everywhere from
the warehouses of Antwerp to coup plots
in West Africa bringing violence
corruption and big profits Bloomberg
reporter Matthew Bristow traveled to
putomayo province in southern Colombia
and visited an eight hectare coca farm
that sells about 40 kilograms of the
drug a year one kilo sells between
thirty thousand dollars in the U.S to
160 thousand dollars in Australia the
farmers make about just over six hundred
dollars for every kilogram that they
produce which isn't very much given that
they also have to pay for all the
chemicals they have to pay for gasoline
so they're left with very little in the
way of profits Colombian cocaine
production began Rising 10 years ago
when the government started negotiations
with the largest Guerrilla group the
farc cocoa production roughly has
tripled since then during the peace
talks the government reduced the amount
of eradication of Coker it was doing the
piece of talks was supposed to lead to
drop in Cocoa production but when the
gorilla is demobilized the areas that
they occupied were filled by new illegal
arms groups and these groups often
threatened to kill people for
cooperating with government programs to
eradicate coca Bill Farms are still
being targeted the new president Gustavo
Petro proposed a different approach to
the war on drugs he says the War on
Drugs pursued by Bogota and Washington
for decades has brought violence to
Latin America while failing to stem
death and addiction in the United States
he wants to go after the mafia and big
shipments of cocaine rather than the
poorest coca farmers
[Music]